hey you guys flickers of fear time
doing another movie review and this is
kind of a recent movie
and one that i'd actually heard a lot
about um like i said i kind of peruse a
lot of those
you know best horror movies in the last
five years last 10 years whatever
just so i can get like a list of you
know stuff that
i want to watch that i can put on my
list and this is one that's been on the
list for a long time
this came out in 2018 and it's called
piercing now this is actually on in the
us i'm not sure about other countries
it's actually on netflix which i didn't
know
uh but i watched it on uh uk shutter
with my vpn
so it's on there as well so if you're in
the uk and you don't have it on netflix
and it should be uh
on your shutter now this movie
has a pretty awesome uh horror pedigree
let's call it that so it was directed by
nicholas
pesh i'm not really sure it's p-e-s-c-e
i'm not really sure how you pronounce
that who was the same guy who
uh debuted back in 2016 with the very
weird black and white movie uh the eyes
of my mother
which i really dug but i knew it was
like really divisive so he directed it
and he wrote the screenplay
however this is actually based on a
novel by
ryu murakami who was the same guy who
wrote the novel that the movie audition
was based on
now if you and from what i've heard i
haven't read the novel but i've heard
that this movie is pretty accurate
to the book so i will say that
if you liked audition then you'll
probably like this as well although i
because it's kind of along the same
lines but i don't
think it's as disturbing or as
gross and you know cringe inducing as
audition was because that one was kind
of hard to sit through
this one has some kind of squeaky [ __ ]
in it
you know and some stuff that's kind of
like but nothing that bad like i was
never
at any point like oh man i can't watch
that uh you know there are some
you know close-ups of somebody piercing
a nipple somebody you know
hitting somebody with a can opener or
whatever it is and like taking part of
their ear off and [ __ ] like that so it
is kind of like that
but you know if you're into gory [ __ ]
and like i said if you were able to sit
through audition then this will be like
a walk in the park
even though this does have some gore in
it but if you're squeamish you probably
would
want to skip it because it's kind of so
as i said this came out in 2018
and it stars christopher abbott who i
immediately recognized because he was in
possessor uh and he was also in vox lux
which is actually a pretty decent movie
if you haven't seen it i kind of i saw
it in the theater and then it just kind
of went nowhere
uh he was also in uh it comes at night
which was also a really decent movie
it also has mia wasikovska who
i also immediately recognized from
crimson peak she was also in
uh only lovers left alive and the devil
all the time uh you know she hasn't been
in a bunch of stuff
so this movie the coolest thing about
this movie i thought
was this is very much
you know audition type [ __ ] like takashi
miike
meets dario argento by way of
cronenberg you know what i'm saying not
as
awesome as like that implies but still
pretty damn good i mean i really really
did like this movie
it seems like it got fairly decent
reviews up in the 75
80 percent a lot of people didn't like
the ending thought the ending was too
abrupt or it was just kind of like oh
that's it
i didn't really get that but i can see
how maybe you would think that
uh so yeah i think that was kind of the
most divisive thing that a lot of people
just really didn't like the way it ended
or
you know that the ending was
anticlimactic or whatever that was like
the main
the main complaint that i saw about this
movie
so you're following this dude reed and
the very first scene of the movie which
you know guarantees to kind of get you
sucked into this
is that he's there with his wife who's
sleeping and his baby
and he's basically like standing over
his baby
gonna stab the baby with the ice pick
right
implication being that this dude is a
serial killer and he has to go out and
kill
random people or he will turn this
proclivity on his own family
so that's basically what the movie is
it's just this guy
and he tells his wife you know he's
going on a business trip
but the whole purpose of this business
trip is he's going to go and stay in
this hotel and he's going to order a
prostitute
he's going to order a prostitute that's
like a funny way of putting it but he's
just
going to call up at escort service and
get a prostitute and he's going to tire
up
and kill her that happens like he does
that and
it's actually kind of funny it's weird
because this movie as [ __ ] up as the
premise is
it has it's almost i don't know if i
want to go as far as to say it's like a
black comedy
but it definitely does have a lot of
[ __ ] up like comedic
funny [ __ ] in it which i don't know i
like that
but maybe some some people i think
thought it was a little jarring but i i
didn't
so i guess the one um
prostitute that he had wanted was not
available
uh because he was like you know he
wanted one that was into like bdsm just
so he would be able to tie her up and
kill her you know so it'd be easier for
him in that way
so he's like before she shows up he's
like practicing which i think is
like kind of funny like it's really
[ __ ] up and funny so he's just kind of
like
going around the room like you know
practicing and there's like sound
effects and stuff while he was
practicing
it's not quite as goofy as it sounds
like when i'm describing it but it's
still pretty funny
so the prostitute he wanted uh was not
available so he gets this other one
jackie now when jackie shows up
she's got uh some of her own issues
which i don't want to kind of spoil it
too much because
this is one of those movies where i
didn't really other than the barest
minimum like this guy's a serial killer
and he calls his prostitute he's gonna
kill her and then
you know but she's not what he bargained
for so that's all i knew going into this
movie
and i think it's good that that's all
you know going into this movie because
this is kind of like like i said if you
saw
audition you'll kind of know it's in
that ballpark
where it's just kind of like a power
dynamic between these two characters
that keep
it keeps kind of going back and forth
between the two of them like you know
and and it also kind of goes back and
forth between
both of them having their own uh like i
said their own kind of [ __ ] up issues
and you're not really entirely sure
like you kind of know what his deal is
because he's clearly like a serial
killer because he's got like a whole
notebook and everything
but you're not really entirely sure what
her deal is and i
don't think you ever really find out
like you can tell what some of her [ __ ]
is
but i don't know there's some place
where it could kind of go either way and
they don't really resolve it but in a
way i kind of liked that that they
didn't really
resolve her character like oh she's this
or she's that it just makes it a lot
more
intriguing so it's like this really
bizarre
kind of gory psychosexual it is a horror
movie it's but it's kind of like it's
mostly just the two of them
like you know in the in the hotel room
in her apartment in the hospital
in you know other places and just kind
of this dynamic like switching back and
forth between them
but it's not like like if you saw his uh
nicholas pech's first
film like the eyes of my mother which
was very like i loved it but it was like
real arty party so i can see why
some likely was real divisive this one
is less already farty although i get
into that in a little bit
and it's not slow i didn't find it slow
at all and it's actually pretty short
it's only like an hour and 21 minutes
long or something like that so it just
kind of like flew by
i don't know it's just a real strange
it's more like a weird character study
i guess than a sort of action-packed but
like i said there is a lot of gore in it
there is a lot of
stabbing there is a lot of like
uncomfortable uh
injuries and things of that nature so
just know that going
into it the thing that is my favorite
thing
about this movie is that he decided
nicholas pesci decided to make it
an homage to
several like particular kinds of
movie subgenres particularly the giallo
and you guys know how much i love that
kind of [ __ ]
so anybody that does anything that's
like an homage to giallo movies i'm all
about that [ __ ]
this one he does some brian de palma
[ __ ] too because he does like a lot of
kind of split screen
like uh you know like brian de palma did
and uh but he goes so far with the
giallo stuff this isn't a yellow movie
necessarily because it's not it doesn't
have that same structure
but visually it kind of looks like that
and i love the way like a lot of it
is real stylized like if you watch the
end credits which i would advise because
they're super cool
they had built these miniatures
of all these little buildings you know
like skyscrapers and stuff
and it just kind of uh the end credits
just kind of go
like panning over like up and down and
across these miniatures and they're
really like amazing
also this movie straight up uses
the music goblin's music from
uh profondo rosso deep red and also from
tenebrae so it actually uses the deep
red main theme
not only during i think the end credits
but it uses it like at one point during
the movie too
and it even has that kind of like real
long tracking shot
type of thing so it's definitely
homaging that and i thought that was
really really cool and i just really
liked that
that aspect of it you know yeah you
could say it's
that he's just like ripping it off or
whatever but i don't you know i didn't
really think of it that way because the
movie is not like a giallo movie
otherwise
but i like that he decided he was going
to make it this stylized
you know just like the look of it the
sound of it and i thought that was
really really cool
so that was probably like my favorite
aspect of this that
and the acting performances which are
phenomenal
which is good because pretty much this
entire movie is just these two
characters
interacting with one another and i liked
that there was kind of
and that's what i meant when i said that
it's better not knowing
too much about where the movie's going
like when you first go into it because
it kind of keeps you on edge the whole
time because you're not really sure like
i said you're kind of sure what his deal
is
but you're not real sure what her deal
is you know what i mean so it could kind
of go anywhere she's kind of a wild card
and so i kind of liked that about it
because i never really knew like which
direction it was gonna go
in and like you know what was gonna
happen so it kept me interested all the
way through
that said i can't understand why some
people uh criticized that the end seemed
kind of abrupt or
that it didn't really like go anywhere
it didn't amount to anything like a lot
of people said it ended and i was like
oh that's it and like
i think i one uh one horror girl i watch
a spooky astronaut she's australian
and um she actually saw this in the
theater when it came out
and i watched her review of it earlier
today and she really loved it up until
the end and she just thought the ending
ruined it uh so she so she
had some kind of strong feelings about
it i didn't think that at all it was
kind of like this big long convoluted
like [ __ ] up thing and then the end
was almost kind of like the punch line
of a joke
i guess but i don't know i kind of dug
that that said it's not
it's not as amazing because like i said
it's very uh
very dario argento very cronenberg it
has some cronenbergian like body horror
type [ __ ] in there
it's kind of got a de palma type of [ __ ]
to it
you know kind of an homage to that era
it's not like i said it's not as
fantastic
as all of those things together like
would imply
but it's still pretty [ __ ] good like
i thought it was really good
i had a good time with it it kind of had
that
[ __ ] up like black humor that i really
like
and i really loved the visuals of it i
love love
that it used uh the deep red like main
title theme it's like when it first came
out of the movie i was just i laughed
out loud i was like no [ __ ] way
because because i love that piece of
music so i love that
i just i loved the little miniatures and
all that and like i said the acting
performances
uh are fantastic so this is definitely
one
that you know if anything like i said if
you liked audition
this is kind of in the same ballpark but
it's not as extreme as that
i don't think you're you know if you
didn't have trouble sitting through
audition i don't think you'll have any
trouble sitting through this this was
not nearly as
revolting as that one was but it's kind
of in the same
wheelhouse i guess so if you liked any
of that stuff that i mentioned
then by all means check it out and tell
me what you thought of it in the
comments
you know did the ending ruin it for you
it didn't for me but i know it did for
some people and i kind of get that
uh but i really liked it i i liked the
performances i just really liked
the vibe of the whole movie like i said
if you're in the u.s not sure about
other countries it is on netflix
which i didn't realize until today uh
but i watched it on uh
shutter uk uh the british shutter so
it's on there as well
uh and that will do it for this flickers
of fear i will see you guys
on the next one bye